PROFESSOR: One more
lecture from me.
And so remember that on
Thursday we'll be here.
And Chris Wolverton from Ford
will be lecturing, straight
live direct from Ford.
And so you better have
good questions for him
because he only
lectures about an hour.
And so we usually--
in the past, we've had
quite some good discussion
afterwards, but that's
going to depend on you.
So what I'm going to do
today is a variety of topics,
but they all have to do with the
same idea of bigger and faster
and better--
not necessarily better.
So when you deal with
atoms, both because
of the size and the
time, if you go away,
especially if you go away
from periodic systems,
you always run into this problem
that it's too small [INAUDIBLE]
system, that the
simulation is too short.
I always like to quote
Professor Marzari on this.
When people come to
him with nano problems,
he always says, nano is just
a little too big for us.
And so I think that's
telling you something
about the state of what we do.
So you've actually seen
certain solutions already
to the sort of size
and time problem.
Maybe they were fairly obvious.
But if you think of the time
problem, what I've already
showed you is how to essentially
coarse grain that away, which
is it's one thing to coarse
grain over time and space.
It's another thing, and
it's actually easier
to almost remove it by,
integrating in a way.
And when you essentially
integrate time away completely,
you end up with thermodynamics.
I mean, thin about it.
That's what integration over
the partition function is.
You're essentially assuming
the system has had enough time
to sample all its
excitations, so we essentially
integrate over that ensemble.
You integrate over
all the excitations,
and you end up with the
thermodynamic functions.
And the examples that I showed
you with the cluster expansion
were essentially
examples like that.
So that part, I would say,
for crystalline systems
is a solved problem.
It's not a trivial solution.
It's still a lot of work,
but it's essentially
a solved problem.
I would say most of
the spatial problem
is solved if you're
going to deal
with static properties,
static properties and things
such as elastic behavior.
You essentially coarse
grain fairly easily
and end up with
continuum theory.
The real problem lies in
what sort of happens in
between here.
When you want to keep some level
of detail that's not continuum
or in the time max
is not thermodynamic,
but you can afford to
stay all the way down
at the atomistic scale and
the scale of the electrons,
that's where I think the
real challenge exists.
And I'll tell you a
little more about that.
That's when you
break your computer.
So first, I'm going to
tell you there's obviously
the brute force approaches,
which is just throw
more computer power at it.
And these days the
way you do that is not
buying faster computers.
You buy more of them.
So you have to parallelize.
Parallelization over space is
obviously the most obvious one.
If you have a really big system,
you can divide it in chunks.
OK, you know?
You'd probably do it a
little more systematic,
but you can divide
it in chunks and give
each chunk of atoms to a CPU,
CPU1, CPU2, CPU3, et cetera.
Of course, that implies that
the coupling between regions
is not too severe.
Because when you calculate--
let's say you're
doing electrodynamics.
When you calculate forces on
the atoms in the region of CPU1,
the atoms that live
in the boundary layer
obviously see forces coming
from atoms in the other regions.
So how efficient this method
is will depend very much
on how well you can divide
the sort of spatial origin
of the forces and the energy.
So you can already
see that this is
going to be easier when you do
it with pair potentials, say.
With pair potentials,
you can directly assign,
when you have the
force on an atom,
the component coming
from other atoms.
You can say the force
on this atom comes--
I have a piece coming
from the potential
with that atom, the potential
with that atom, et cetera.
You'll see that in the
standard approximation,
for example, the
quantum mechanics,
this is virtually impossible.
When we work with
block states, those
are, by definition, extended
over the whole system, OK?
So you can't partition
them over pieces of space.
So to do this sort of
divide and conquer approach
with quantum mechanics,
you have to go
to alternative approaches.
People invest a lot of time
now in just real space grids.
In theory, the
Schrodinger equation
is a partial
differential equation.
Like any other partial
differential equation,
you should be able to solve
it on a real space grid.
There's all kinds of
complications that arise,
but people are doing a lot--
there's a lot of work actually
being done on that.
The other is to go to
localized basis sets.
And you know, maximally
localized Wannier functions
fall in that category.
And Professor Marzari
is an expert on that,
almost essentially invented--
tight binding approaches.
So you'll see a lot of work
being done on real space
methods, which is, in
essence, directed largely
towards this sort of divide
and conquer approach.
If you can go a real space
in quantum mechanics,
you can divide space up.
So space is maybe, in
the end, not the biggest
problem we have to deal with.
Time is a much harder one.
Because how do you
parallelize over time?
Time is, by nature, sequential.
So it's really hard
to do something
that's in the future when you
don't know the present yet.
But you'll see in a second--
well, not in a second, a
little more than a second,
but later in the lecture.
There are some approaches
to paralyzing time,
but they're all, I
would say, much more
limited in scope
than the methods
for parallelizing over space.
So you see time will
be the big problem.
Time is easy to deal with when
it's either short or very long.
Because when it's very long, you
essentially integrate it away.
But in between is where
it tends to get harder.
So let me give you sort
of a couple of examples
of ideas that have
been kicked around
for coarse-graining space.
And then I'll say a little
more about the time.
And with time comes
temperature problem.
So you could imagine, if you
do an impurity calculation--
so you take a sort of crystal
of these bluish atoms,
and you stick a big red atom in.
You want to calculate
the energy [INAUDIBLE]
with quantum mechanics.
Well, those shells around the
red atom kind of relax a lot.
And then as you
sort of go further,
this is largely an
elastic problem.
You've put a ball in a
hole that's too small,
and sort of the system
relaxes around it.
We tend to sort of brute
force that typically.
We do quantum mechanics on
bigger and bigger units cells.
But it's actually
remarkable if you ever
plot the displacements.
You will find that these systems
behave remarkably elastically
in very close shells
to the defect already.
Often, from the
second, third neighbor,
if you were to apply
elasticity theory,
you'd still get it right.
It's amazing how applicable
elasticity theory
is at the atomistic level.
So that gave people the
idea that really when
they do calculations with broken
symmetry, so around defects,
maybe you really don't
need all the atoms that we
tend to put in calculations.
So the idea that's
been kicked around
is that let's say that this
is a piece of your simulation
that's far away from whatever
perturbation you're looking at.
Maybe it's a grain boundary.
Maybe it's a dislocation moving.
Maybe you just
did nuclear fusion
somewhere in the material.
But far away, you believe
that the system acts almost
in a continuum mode.
And so the idea is
that, what if I kept
track only of these red atoms?
Let's say I'm looking at energy
of an elastic displacement
or even not elastic.
If I knew how these
four items moved,
I could probably know something
about how the other atoms move,
OK?
So I could interpolate,
say, their displacement
from the displacement
of the corner atoms.
So one thing you
can do is say, well,
if I know how
these atoms move, I
assume that the energy
of the atoms in between
is essentially the same as an
energy of a sort of macroscopic
solid that I deform
with that displacement.
You can do things in between.
You can actually
sort of calculate
the energy of that unit
cell as it's displaced.
But the whole idea
that essentially you
start keeping only track of
a limited number of atoms.
And you can think
of these as nodes.
So these are called nodal atoms.
And what happens to all
the atoms you removed--
you essentially get
by interpolation.
And once you're happy with
using elasticity theory,
then essentially
you know the energy
of that cube, how that changes
as you change the four corners.
Typically, people use triangles
because people will tend
to use triangular measures.
But I wanted to give the
example with a square
since it's a little simpler.
So this is essentially the idea
of the quasi continuum method.
Let's say out here you
have some perturbation,
something you want to study
at the atomistic level.
As you go farther and farther
away, you want to coarse grain
more and more.
So essentially, you want to
keep less and less nodal atoms
and get more and
more information
simply by interpolation.
So you could say this is coarse
graining at the level of one
out of four when you're here.
And then you have a
few regions of that.
And then you coarse
grain at a higher level.
So you keep, say, I should
have removed-- sorry,
these should not be red.
These should be blue, sorry.
So you only keep
these four atoms,
and you sort of
assume that that solid
undergoes a homogeneous
deformation within that box.
What you see is that
somewhere in this limit
you're going to end up
with a finite element
approaches, where essentially
you do continuum theory.
And you essentially
say that, if I
know some displacements of
elements, of the corner points,
the vertices of elements, I know
how to that element deforms.
So what you have is essentially
a sort of continuous transition
here in coarse graining
from our atomistic behavior
to a finite element approach.
And people have
put that together.
And this is called a
quasi-continuum approach.
This is sort of a
pictorial version of it.
Let's say this is some boundary
where you do something.
You have very fine resolution.
You could say the nodes of
your finite element niche
are the atoms.
And then as you go
farther and farther away,
you coarse grain more and more.
And you keep less
and less information.
I'll give you a
reference at the end,
but the people
who developed this
were essentially a
fairly small group
of people, Shenoi,
Tadmor, and Rob Phillips,
and Michael Ortiz at Caltech.
And there's some excellent
review papers about this
if you'd like to
read more about this.
It's now been fairly
well-implemented,
these kind of approaches, mainly
with empirical energy methods.
People have tried to implement
it with quantum mechanics.
And some people have
actually done it,
but it's not all that
effective really.
It's extremely hard to
couple the atomistic region
where you do quantum
mechanics to a sort
of more coarse grained region.
But with potentials and with
things like embedded atom
method, people have
coupled these things
fairly well together.
This is, for example,
a grain boundary--
sorry, a crack impinging
on a grain boundary.
See, this is a symmetric
grain boundary.
And you have the crack
in the middle there.
It comes in, hits
the grain boundary,
and essentially deflects
in the grain boundary.
So that's a simulation
done with quasi-continuum.
You know, if you want to
think about it, what it really
does for you
quasi-continuum, is that it's
a way of getting the
boundary conditions right
on your atomistic simulation.
By slowly integrating
it, essentially
with a continuum theory, you,
first of all, have adaptive--
your boundary conditions or
your atomistic simulation
change during the simulation.
And because you have a
better embedding theory,
you have a better
continuum theory,
they're sort of
more appropriate.
And especially in
mechanical problems,
that is very important to have
the right elastic boundary
conditions.
So let me sort of
position this for you
to show you where
we have the solution
and where we still have
significant problems.
You know, I would
essentially say,
when we work purely at
the microscopic scale,
we have most things
under control.
We know well how to deal
with the energetics.
We fairly well how to
deal with the dynamics.
Because for pretty
much everything,
except things like hydrogen, you
can use Newtonian dynamics even
on the atomistic scale.
You could argue we
don't really know
how to deal well with
electron dynamics,
but that's another problem.
If you're willing to go all
the way to the continuum scale,
we also know the equations
that describe matter.
It's essentially
thermodynamics and elasticity.
And you could think
of thermodynamics
as the integrator of those.
It's when we live at this
inhomogeneous coarse grain
scale that we're
really in trouble.
And I'll give you an example.
Think of temperature.
In continuum theory,
temperature is a field.
In a microscopic
simulation, it's
kinetic energy of the atoms.
You can already see
a problem appear.
Essentially, as you
inhomogeneously coarse grain
around that atomistic
region, that temperature
has to evolve from being
the kinetic energy of motion
to a field.
And it's [INAUDIBLE] tricky to
know what you do in between.
I mean, I know how to deal
with temperature as a field.
I know how to deal with
this kinetic energy.
But what is it in between?
What is it when you say a
factor of 10 coarse grain,
so you've removed
every 10th atom?
And I'm going to go a little
deeper in some of these things,
but those are some
of the problems.
We also don't know what the
dynamics here is at this scale.
Because think of how do
you dissipate energy.
How do you dissipate energy
in a microscopic system?
You dissipate it, essentially,
by non-harmonic vibrations.
That's how you dissipate energy.
How do you dissipate it here?
Actually, you don't unless
you put it inexplicitly.
And in perfectly
elasticity theory,
you don't have dissipation.
So again, energy
dissipation is a big deal
in inhomogeneously
coarse-grained systems.
Because the mechanism by which
it happens at the atomistic
and at the continuum
scale is different.
So quasi-continuum approaches
have been extremely successful
for elastic static
properties and even
nonlinear elastic problems.
It's when people try
to put temperature
and dynamics in that life
gets a lot more complicated.
So there are essentially
two approaches that
have been suggested and tried.
And both sort of
seem reasonable,
but have significant failures.
One is to simply--
let's say, how would you
do molecular dynamics
on a coarse grain
system like this?
Well, remember, you've
removed these atoms.
You could lump their
mass into the nodes.
So essentially, the nodes of
your mesh now become heavier.
And then you do MD on those.
The problem with
that is that, as you
coarse grain more
and more, you get
the heavier and heavier nodes.
And after a while, they
don't move anymore.
Because if they have
the same temperature,
mv squared average over
2 is the temperature.
So at the same temperature,
the v becomes very small.
The other one is a sort
of often used approach
to use static optimizations.
But rather than say get all
the positions of these atoms--
rather than get them
from the energy,
get them from minimizing
the free energy.
Say, the force would
be now the gradient
of something like
the free energy
rather than the
gradient of the energy.
So you have some amount of
temperature effects in there
then, but you don't
truly have dynamics.
So one thing this would do
for you, for example, is you'd
get the right bond length
and lattice parameters.
OK.
I want to show you some other
ideas that have been out there.
This is one that I've
worked on for a short while.
But the generic idea has
really being out there
in the community a long time.
And it's very similar
to what we've done
in the coarse graining of time.
The idea is essentially think
of three atoms on a chain,
1, 2, 3 there.
What if you want to remove
atom 2, and so coarse grain
and only keep 1
and 3 as the nodes?
The question really is,
what should your potential--
let's say you do
this with potentials.
Don't even worry about
quantum mechanics.
What should your
potential between 1 and 3
be, so that they behave the
same way as if 2 were there?
So you're going to
take 2 out, but you
want to set up a
potential between 1 and 3
that acts like if 2 were there.
Well, you can get the solution
again from thermodynamics,
essentially requiring
that the partition
function for the
motion of 1 and 3
is the same with
or without 2 there.
And that's essentially
what's written out here.
If you think of q's and
p's for the coordinates,
remember q's are spatial
coordinates. p's are
velocities,
essentially the moment.
Essentially, what
you're saying is
that the free energy
of the Hamiltonian
with only q1 and q3--
so now, you keep only the
positions of 1 and 3--
is obtained by integrating
away the coordinates of 2.
So you integrate
over the position
and over the momentum of 2.
And if the motions
are classical,
then the integration over
the momentum is trivial.
You always get the same
factors from momentum.
So it's really the integration
over the coordinates.
And so if you integrate
this away, then
formally this integral has no
q2 dependence by definition.
You've essentially integrated
over all possible displacements
of 2 to get the interaction
between 1 and 3.
And so that then defines a
potential just between 1 and 3.
Now, there's all kinds
of practical issues.
You can really only
do this effectively
if you have interactions
that are spatially limited.
Because, otherwise,
you really don't know
what you all have to integrate.
So this works great with
pair potentials then.
So you know, what does
this physically mean?
It really means that, if
you, say, displace atom three
and you look at the force
that it produces on atom 1,
that you're looking at
the kind of screening
by atom 2 is included.
In the real system, atom
2 would sort of maybe
screen that displacement
away somewhat.
And that's not included.
And people have
done this before,
looking at interactions of--
when you look at interactions
of ions and fluids,
the way to look
at the interaction
between two ions
is by integrating over the
possible displacement of all
the other ones in between.
And that's how you
end up with screening.
So this is sort of the
screening equivalent
in displacement fields.
And what you get at is very
much what you'd expected.
This is the potentials
for different levels
of coarse graining in
normalized distances.
So if the length of the bond
length is in units of 1,
so this would be the
normal potential.
If you coarse grain one level,
so you remove every other atom,
you actually end
up with a potential
that's twice the bond length.
Because, remember, now
you have atom 1, 2, 3.
You've removed 2, so
the equilibrium distance
between 1 and 3 is about
2 times the bond length.
And you keep on coarse
graining, and you end up
with a potential that's 4
times the bond length, 8
times the bond length.
OK.
It turns out that special
coarse graining always
tends to cause some
kind of time quartering.
That's a much more
difficult issue.
I don't want to say much.
In 1D, it's easy to
remove atoms and add up.
So when you remove atom
2 that's between 1 and 3,
essentially that defines a
potential between 1 and 3.
In 2D, it's a little harder
how you partition bonds,
but you can do all kinds of
bond moving approximations.
This is a simple one
in a triangular lattice
where, if you have a
triangle, you essentially
want to remove these guys here.
And so you can
define some scheme
by which you sort of collapse
the bonds onto these sides.
You can also define
other schemes.
So here's an example of an
inhomogeneously coarse-grained
system in 2D where, in this
case, it's fine at the edges
and it's coarse in the middle.
OK.
There are essentially two
major problems with almost
any coarse-graining scheme.
And the first one is the
worst, is that whenever
you go from a--
let's say you're
atomistic out here.
Here, you've coarse-grained
level 4, coarse-grained
another factor of 4.
You cannot sustain
short wavelength phonons
in the coarse regions.
Let's say you have a
phonon come in here
that's, say, has a
wavelength like this.
Since here you only
have these nodes,
this is essentially the minimum
wavelength you can have.
It's the minimum bond distance.
So at every interface
between a fine region
and of coarser
region, what happens
is that there's a
series of phonons.
The ones that have a wavelength
that's too short get reflected
back because they cannot
go into the coarser region.
And ultimately, you hit
the continuum region,
and you can't have any phonons.
Because there they should all
be dissipated as temperature.
So what does that cause?
Well, if you look at
dynamical processes,
let's say you have a fine
region in which you have
some reaction that dissipates
energy or that creates energy,
the way that that
energy has to get out
is by phonon transmission.
You have to send
lattice vibrations
out which, through
their n harmonicity,
have to get
dissipated somewhere.
And so any time
you block phonons,
you're essentially reducing
the thermal conductivity
of the system.
So this coarse graining gives
you lower thermal conductivity.
And I'll show you some
examples in a second.
But you know, it
does worse things.
It's essentially
elastically confining, also,
your system somewhat, but
only in a dynamical sense.
So it's like you're
having, for certain,
dynamical nodes,
a small unit cell.
And so that means
that they reflect back
of the coarse
graining interface.
And they hit your
region of action
fairly quickly as soon as
they're reflected back.
So it's exactly the same
as putting your dynamics
in a very small box except
that the size of the box
that the system
fields is different
for different wavelengths.
So a certain amount of
elastic behavior gets
reflected back fairly quickly.
So the phonon transmission
problem is a serious one.
And the phonon
transmission one is usually
recognized very well.
There's one that's not
as well recognized,
but is probably in
the long-term just as
severe, is any time
you remove degrees
of freedom you remove entropy.
Because the entropy
is essentially
a count of your
degrees of freedom.
You may not worry about that.
But the problem is that,
if you do dynamics,
your system will equilibrate
along certain derivatives
of the entropy.
And you'll get them wrong.
If you get the
entropy wrong, you'll
get its derivatives wrong.
And some of the ones
that you may worry about
are heat capacity,
which is the temperature
derivative of the entropy,
but also this one, which
you may worry a lot
more about if you
do mechanical behavior, thermal
expansion, which is the volume
derivative of the entropy.
Remember your Maxwell relations?
The sdv is essentially
dv dt up to some factors.
So how the entropy
changed with volume
determines the
thermal expansion.
And that's why, if you
actually look back,
the slide I showed
you, when we define
the effective potential
between atoms 1 and 3,
there's actually a potential.
And then there's a part
that doesn't contain
the coordinates of 1 and 3.
And it's essentially the entropy
you've lost by removing node 2.
You have to actually keep
that entropy in the system
if you want to get the total
thermodynamic qualities right.
It's sort of like you
see that this is obvious
if you take the complete
limit of removing all nodes
or going to 1 node.
Then you end up with
continuum behavior.
And the degrees of freedom
of continuing behavior
are not the entropy.
You've actually removed
all the dynamic motion
when you go through
continuum theory.
So unless you've kept track
of the degrees of freedom
and the entropy
that they include,
you've lost all your
information about that.
So when you do something
like this here,
these will actually, if
you define the potentials
at a given temperature, because
the renormalization potential
depends on temperature--
if you define this at
a given temperature
and you run this at
any other temperature,
these regions will have
different thermal expansions.
And so you'll build up
internal strain in your system
without knowing it.
I get a new color scheme.
There we go.
So if you take a simple
pair potential model,
these coarse graining
schemes work pretty well.
Here's essentially
a static property
even though it has
temperature in it,
but this is the strain in that
2D system versus the stress.
And the black curve
underlying this
is the full system,
so no coarse graining.
And the red curve is that coarse
grain system that I showed you.
And you'll see even in the
non-linear part does this
very well.
And it makes sense, you know.
This kind of mechanical
behavior, strain versus stress,
is largely dominated
by the potentials
in this kind of solid system.
There's very little dynamical
factors that play a role in it.
So as long as you normalize
the potentials right,
you will get the stress-strain
relation right even
in the non-linear regime.
So that's not a big surprise.
If you keep track of
the entropy right,
you'll get things like
the heat capacities right.
This is the ratio
between the heat capacity
in the non-homogeneous system,
which is the coarse grain
system, divided by the
exact result, you could say,
the heat capacity
in the homogeneous.
It essentially
oscillates around one
as a function of temperature.
So by construction you
pretty much have that right.
So here gets more interesting.
If you look at heat
conduction through
a coarse grained interface--
so let's say you're
fine at this side.
Let's say these are atoms.
And here we've removed a bunch
of nodes with coarse grains.
And so you look at the heat
conduction through this.
So you set up a
temperature gradient
and essentially look at the
heat flux when you do dynamics.
So what this is showing
here is the heat conduction
in the non-homogeneous system
divided by the heat conduction
in the homogeneous system.
And this is pretty much
always lower than 1.
So the non-homogeneous system
has less heat conduction.
And the reason is you scatter
phonons on this interface.
So here there is
a certain amount
of phonons that
get reflected back.
But it's interesting.
If you show this
here as a function
of the length of the
homogeneous system,
you do better and better
as this system gets bigger.
And that makes sense because
then the interface becomes
less and less important.
But, you know, look
at the size here.
To get up to sort
of about 1, you
need about 1,500 atoms in
the homogeneous region.
So this is a major problem
with full phonons in general.
I think of any atomistic level
phenomena phonons are probably
the ones that have the
largest length scale.
The phonon mean free
[INAUDIBLE] at a low temperature
is enormous.
It's thousands of atoms far.
That means that phonons
are usually the first thing
to see something far away.
They're the first thing to
see finite size effects.
They're the first to see
scattering of interfaces.
Because the reason is
that a lot of systems
behave at low temperature
fairly harmonic.
That means that
these phonons just
travel and travel and travel.
And their probability
of being scattered
is pretty low because it's
only as they start becoming
enharmonic that they scatter.
Of course, they could
scatter off disorder.
So if you have the
disordered systems,
the mean free pattern
is a lot lower.
But phonons you often
see hundreds of angstrom
far, essentially.
OK, here's the same result
as a function of temperature.
So the heat capacity versus the
normalized temperature, this
is the real system.
So this is a fully
atomistic level system.
And this, in red here,
is the partially coarse
grained system, in this
case with two interfaces.
Now, what you see is the coarse
grained system always has
lower heat conductance.
They tend to come a
little closer together
at higher temperature.
And the reason is at
higher temperature
you have more enharmonicity.
So the phonons have a
shorter mean free path.
So they tend to
homogenizer easier
and don't see the
interfaces as much.
OK, let me skip this.
OK.
So that's some of the efforts
going on in coarse graining
over space.
I think if there's
an area in which you
want to work and have high
impact, this is probably one.
I haven't seen a
single good idea
in this field in
the last 10 years.
I probably shouldn't
say this on tape,
but, you know, this
is a field where
progress is desperately needed.
And it's a really,
really hard problem.
Because you're essentially
asking the question,
what is the dynamics of
partially coarse-grained
systems?
And the reason it's
so hard is that it's
a mixture of sort of
Newtonian mechanics, which
is energy conserving,
and dissipated dynamics.
And you have to
sort of-- and that
how you mix those
essentially depends
on the frequency of your motion.
And that's why this is
such a hard problem.
People have tried
things with boundaries
that have complex
impedances, where
essentially your transmission
through the boundary
is frequency dependent.
And you can see,
with that one, you
can definitely sort of tailor
better what the phonons do.
Because, now, you have a
much more complex interface
literally to control.
The problem is that some of
these things you can make work,
but they get so complicated
to implement that they're not
necessarily very practical.
Other people do things with
large overlapping regions.
You could say one way
to solve this problem is
to not have these
sharp boundaries
between different levels
of coarse graining,
but overlap the two regions
and slowly force them
in the overlap region.
The solution, say, to
the displacements fields
are the same.
OK.
The next thing I want to talk
about is accelerating time.
I said without Einstein,
but I think Einstein only
could slow down time.
Is isn't that right?
I'm not sure we
can accelerate, no?
I don't know.
I don't know my theory of
relativity too well anymore.
I think I don't have to
convince you-- you've done MD--
why you need to speed
up time sometimes.
Most of what I'm
going to say comes out
of this review
article by Art Voter,
who's probably been the guy to
work on accelerated MD methods.
And I'll give you the
references again at the end.
This is a great
review if you want
to read about this
because there's
some really clever stuff
in here that I think,
even if you don't want
to do accelerated MD,
that you could use
for other things.
So first of all,
what's the problem?
The problem is obviously
that, in most systems that
are fairly dense, you have
well-defined minimum phase
space.
And often the barriers
between them are pretty high.
So you sample the
transitions between them
at a very low rate.
The rate is essentially
proportional to the exponential
of the activation barrier
between the minimum.
And like I said, in a
lot of condensed systems,
those activation
barriers are quite high
and lead to timescales that
you can't quite sample.
So I'm going to talk briefly
about three different methods
to speed up time
parallel replica
dynamics, hyperdynamics,
and temperature accelerated
dynamics.
OK.
Let me sort of quickly
review what you would do
with transition state theory.
So if you knew the transitions
that a system had to make, like
in, say, a simple
molecular reaction,
then you really don't
need to do a simulation.
Because if the activation
barrier, this quantity and you
have some idea of the frequency
with which the system tries
to cross that barrier, you
can do transition state theory
and essentially say that
the crossing rate is going
to be something like
the attempt rate,
nu, times the success rate,
which is this Boltzmann factor.
And the chemists among
you and chemical engineers
know there's all kinds of
approximations in there.
But none of them are
particularly severe for most
things to study.
Like, one approximation just
assumes you don't cross back.
Often, when you sit at
the transition state,
you're essentially
assuming that you
fall over and don't cross back.
The other approximation
is that this
assumes that the
transitions are infrequent
compared to the
vibrations in the minimum.
So you assume that when the
system goes from here to here
it's sort of equilibrates
here, vibrates
around until it makes
the next transition.
And the reason you
need to do that
is that you need to equilibrate
first in every potential well
before you go to the next one.
Because, otherwise, you
have dynamical memory left
from the previous transition,
which would essentially
change your statistic, would
make your statistical mechanics
approach invalid.
But usually those are
easy to deal with.
It's sort of obvious.
Because if you think about
it, if the system crosses very
rapidly compared to
the time it vibrates,
then you just do
molecular dynamics
because then you have
very fast transition.
So who cares about
transition state theory?
OK.
So the parallel replica
method is really
kind of elegant in
its triviality almost.
If you think of what is time,
time is waiting for events
to happen.
And if you think of a
really trivial example,
let's say the system wants
to move from this state
to that state.
You're just sitting there.
The atoms are vibrating around.
And you're waiting for
a system to transition.
Why not wait on many
processors at a time?
So the idea is you
run this simulation
on a bunch of processors.
And if you run on,
say, 100, you could
say that's kind of like
waiting 100 times the time you
wait on one processor.
And then let's say it
happens on one processor.
The system transitions.
Then you essentially add up
all the time all the systems
have waited, and that's
your total waiting time.
And in a statistical sense,
that's actually right.
If you do queuing theory
and things like that,
you'll find that
this is the solution.
It's actually easy to
see if you turn this
all into probabilities
for transfer.
Essentially, you could say,
when you do it 100 times,
you've 100 times
attempted or given
the system chances in a given
time to make a transition.
So you add up all the time,
and then you just restart.
So you put the system
in the next state.
And you again run
all those replicas.
You have to introduce a
little bit of randomization,
of course.
You don't want these to follow
exactly the same trajectory
through phase space.
So there's a certain amount
of randomization that goes on.
So essentially, this
is linear time scaling.
Overall, you pretty much--
if you have n processors,
time is accelerated by a
factor of n you could say.
It's a little less
because there's overhead.
You have to, first of all,
do the non-trivial thing,
which is detect the transition.
When you think about it, this
is kind of not that trivial.
You're doing your MD simulation.
And you've got to sort
of ask your system, oh,
has something happened?
And maybe it's, like, an
atom diffusing, whatever.
So you've got to do quite a
bit of work to sort of check
whether a transition
that happens.
So you've got overhead there.
And then you have overhead when
you sort of copy the transition
state into all the other ones.
You have to do a little
bit of randomization here.
So typically you may restart
with an actual Boltzmann
distribution of
velocities and so.
But you have to initialize that.
You have to run that
for a very short time.
And so you have a bit
of overhead there.
So you'll get a little
less than end scaling.
But it's not bad.
It's not great either.
But like I said, with
1,000 processors,
you can go from nanoseconds
to microseconds.
So yeah, that's not bad.
I mean, you can see
that you're never
going to make it to seconds
because of the linear scaling.
But it is a sort of intermediate
timescale that can be useful.
Here's an example.
This is planarization
of silver on silver.
And this comes straight
out of Art Voter's article.
So essentially, this is a
1, 1, 1 layer of silver.
That's the white atoms.
And then on top of
that is a first layer,
which is the blue atoms.
And then the yellow atoms
is another layer on top.
OK, so you're
seeing three layers.
And so this study tracks
how the system planarizes
to lower its surface energy.
So the top atoms should
sort of come down
and form all one island.
And so this is perfect
for accelerated MD.
I mean, researchers know
why they pick problems
because they can solve them.
Because this is a set
of discrete events.
You know, atoms diffuse and
maybe even collectively.
You see, the nice thing
about MD is that you're not
imposing the kinetic mechanism.
But it's still a set
of discrete events.
So atoms may help a
little-- you can see it
in the first few slides
there-- and ultimately
sort of planarize.
People got all the way
up to 1 microsecond.
Although it was done
with empirical potential.
And according to Art Voter,
this took only about five days
on 32 Pentiums.
And these are old.
I mean, these are 1
gigahertz Pentiums,
so probably do it in
maybe one to two days now.
I think you can already
see, if I go back,
when this will not work.
This will not work if the
overhead becomes excessive.
And how is it going
to become excessive--
if you start getting
a lot of transitions.
If only after a little
bit of simulation
you get a transition,
then your overhead
starts to weigh heavily.
And when is that
going to happen?
Well, it's going to
happen, of course, when you
have low activation barriers.
But there's another
problem which
is a little more
severe, if you make
your system bigger and bigger.
See the probability-- let's
say you have a system that's
sort of locally identical.
If you make it
bigger and bigger,
the probability that
a transition occurs--
let's say an atom diffuses--
is proportional to
the system size.
The probability that
an event happens
is proportional to
the system size.
So as you make the
system bigger and bigger,
this essentially becomes
less and less efficient
because you get more
and more transitions.
And that's something you'll
see in other versions
of accelerated MD as well.
OK.
Hyperdynamics, I like
the word very much,
but I'm not going to
say much about it.
Hyperdynamics is really
a class of methods
that is getting very popular
not just in accelerating MD now.
But the whole idea of
modifying the potential surface
is getting sort of
very popular also
for pure optimization methods.
If you think that this is the
surface of the original system,
this is the energy
surface, your problem
is that these
wells are too deep.
Well, solve the problem
by lifting them up.
So if you can define
a potential that
tracks the original
potential in most of space,
especially the activated
pieces, but then lifts up
the minima of the well,
if your system moves
on the red potential,
it's going to transition
a lot faster because the
activation barrier goes down
a lot.
And you can actually run
the system on the red curve
and correct for the
transition rate.
Because, see, the cool
thing is that once
the MD finds the transitions--
so MD is going back
and forth here.
But once it's found
the transition,
you could calculate back
what the real barrier
should have been.
So you know at what
rate the system should
have transitioned.
So boosting the potential
surface with this boost
potential-- that's
this difference here,
boosting it up--
is essentially accelerating
the escape from the minimum.
And you can correct back by
this Boltzmann factor, which
is essentially comes from
the ratio of the proper rate
to the rate that you actually
had in your MD simulation.
There's all kinds
of tricks involved.
This is a simplified
version of it.
There's a lot of
questions about how
you define that boost surface.
For example, do you want to
keep the same frequencies?
So then you'd like to keep
the curvature the same.
Because then you keep the
same attempt frequencies,
but you're only
changing the success
rate of crossing the barrier.
That's a very elegant
way of doing it.
And people have ways
that they can do this.
So doing this in
practice often means
calculating derivatives
of potential surfaces,
in many cases even Hessians, so
matrices of second derivatives.
And that's easy to do
when you have potentials.
It's a lot harder to do when
you're doing quantum mechanics.
And so it's, again,
one of these things
that is usually only done
with empirical potentials.
Actually, I don't know of any
implementation with quantum
mechanics, but it may
be something I've just
missed in the literature.
This is used for sort of
other schemes as well.
If you for a second don't
care about dynamics,
there are now schemes out there
to use this for optimization.
If you think of
global optimization
of a system is a big
problem because there's
all kinds of local wells,
well, what you can do
is, if you fall in a
well, you essentially
start filling up the well.
It's sort of like water
filling up the well
until you fall out
into the next well.
OK.
And then you start
filling up that well
until you fall in next well.
And it's sort of like
water cascading down
an energy surface.
And it's a way to do
global optimization
in a landscape of many minima.
I think this method
was developed
by people at Princeton.
So that's sort of in the
category of hyperdynamics.
The one that's
actually very practical
is the next one, which is
temperature accelerated
dynamics, which is, again,
a sort of obvious idea.
If stuff runs too slow
at low temperature,
run it at higher temperatures.
It'll go faster.
That's actually something
people have often done in MD
without much justification.
What Art Voter's group
did in Los Alamos
is essentially give
this a justification
and show how you can
correct for that temperature
difference between where
you would like the result
and where you're
actually simulating.
And so the idea of
TAD, as it's called,
is to use the high temperature
to find the transitions,
but then execute them
with the proper rate
of the low temperature.
So essentially, you run
at high temperature.
So you fairly quickly scan
the potential surface.
And that tells you what
the transitions are.
And then you go back
to the low temperature,
and you do a sort of
statistical mechanics,
a kind of kinetic
Monte Carlo scheme
or a transition state
theory approach and execute
the transitions.
So I'll show you an example.
The idea is that you
run at high temperature
until a transition occurs.
Once you find the
transition, it's
a trivial matter of finding
the activation barrier.
Then you reverse the
transition, and you run again
at high temperature.
And the idea is that you get
this catalog of transitions.
So you get this catalog
of possible transitions.
Now, why do you need
more than one, you say?
Well, the reason is that the
one you find at high temperature
may not be the one
that actually gets
executed at low temperature.
If they have different
activation barriers,
then their rates may
cross with temperature.
Here's an example.
If I show the crossing
rate versus 1 over t,
let's say you run
at high temperature.
If these behave Arrhenius,
then their crossing rate,
which is 1 over the
time you have to wait,
goes like 1 over t.
You may find one that
has a high crossing rate
at high temperature and this
one that has a lower crossing
rate at high temperature.
But if they have a different
activation barrier,
they'll extrapolate differently
to lower temperature.
But what you see
at low temperature,
the one with the high
rate at high temperature
has the lower rate
at low temperature.
So because transitions have
different activation barriers,
they may not be in the same
order, so the same frequency,
the same rate at
different temperatures.
And that's why you
need a catalog of them.
You essentially need
a window of rates,
of transmission rates, that
give you a certain certainty
that at the lower temperature
you found the lowest one.
And you can kind of do back
of the envelope calculations.
If you make some assumptions
about the range in which
your EAs, your activation
barrier, can vary,
then you have the range of
slopes of these Arrhenius
walls.
So that can tell you a
little bit about how long
you should be running
at the high temperature
to make sure you found
all the transitions
or are likely to have found
all the transitions that
get executed at the
low temperature.
So does everyone see the idea?
You're essentially
using molecular dynamics
as a way of finding transitions.
And that's the hard problem
in any kinetic from.
It's finding the transitions.
Once you find them, you can
calculate their activation
barrier.
And you can execute them with
standard rate constant theory.
But it's finding them.
And MD, because it's unbiased,
is great at doing that.
OK.
So the approximations of the
method are fairly obvious.
To do this extrapolation, you
assume harmonic transition
state theory.
So you essentially assume that
you have a simple Arrhenius
extrapolation
between temperature,
so that the exponential
factor is constant.
And like I said before,
you have to make sure
that you found all
the mechanisms,
that you found enough
mechanisms at high temperature,
so you definitely have the
fastest one at low temperature.
OK.
And here's another application
out of Art Voter's work.
This is copper on
copper deposition.
So they literally, I think,
add atoms to a surface
and then equilibrate them.
And they run-- so they do
direct MD for 2 picoseconds.
That's how the deposit
the atom, but then run
0.3 seconds of
intervening time with TAD.
Now, you may think, 0.3
seconds, that's a lot.
Well, it's not
because you're really
doing transition state theory.
If I have barriers of 1 electron
volt, then pretty much at room
temperature 1
electron volt, that
tends to give you rates
around 1 per second.
That's kind of the time scale.
So if you have barriers
of 1 electron volt,
then every time
you execute a step,
you're 1 second
further on average.
So the 0.3 seconds, that
is not that impressive.
You know, I can do 1,000
seconds with one step
just by having a system at a
very high activation barrier.
OK.
You can look at the different
events in the simulation.
And one of the nice things
is, because you're doing MD,
your system is unbiased.
And one thing we've
learned more and more
by doing MD on surfaces is that
the diffusive processes are not
at all the way people
thought they were.
People think of atoms
hopping by themselves.
But because surfaces
have so much open space,
have such a low
symmetry, you see
a lot of collective behavior.
For example, here's one.
This blue atom here
pushes in the surface,
pushing that orange atom or
kind of-- what is it-- brown.
And that pushes
then these two out.
And that's all one
collective event.
So these are not things
you would easily guess at.
Here's another
collective event of sort
of a kind of roll of atoms
three at a time at a step edge,
essentially kind of moving down.
OK.
So you typically need MD
methods whenever you don't know
or you're not absolutely
sure what the transmission
mechanisms are.
If you know what the
transmission mechanisms are,
then it tends to be much more
efficient to do Monte Carlo.
You can set up
kinetic Monte Carlo
schemes that execute transitions
with the right transfer rate.
It's just that you have to know
what those transitions are.
So you've already done Monte
Carlo on lattice models,
but we saw it as
a sampling method.
You could also, now, see
it as a kinetic method.
Let's say you have
a lattice of atoms.
Let's make it easier
even, atoms and vacancies.
So we've shown you how
to do the thermodynamics.
Well, let's say you
want to study diffusion.
If you know microscopically
how this atom would migrate
to there, through which
path it would do that,
then you just calculate
the energy along that path.
And you can now do
a Monte Carlo where
the way you travel
through phase space
is by a real kinetic mechanism.
OK.
So you could now take
your exchange rate,
dependent not only on
the energy of the initial
and the final state,
which is the way we did it
in a Metropolis
algorithm, but also
have a prefactor
now that's kinetic.
So that has a frequency
times an activation barrier.
And that's essentially
kinetic Monte Carlo.
OK.
But you see, kinetic
Monte Carlo implies
that you know what
your possible migration
mechanisms are between states.
And usually you know that
reasonably well in things
like crystalline solids.
So there kinetic Monte
Carlo is very applicable.
People also use it on
surfaces even though it
gets a little more dicey there.
But once, of course,
you go to sort
of very disordered
systems, it really
gets way out of hand what
the kinetic mechanisms are.
And this wouldn't work anymore.
So I was going to show you
one example to sort of end up.
And on the continuity,
I was going
to take the same example that
we did for the phase stability.
If you remember this when
we talked about the cluster
expansion, we looked
at the phase diagram
of lithium and lithium vacancies
and lithium cobalt oxide.
So remember the issue is
that, if you take lithium out,
you create vacancies there.
And the issue was how
did they organize.
And I showed you how to
use a cluster expansion
to do the phase diagram,
the thermodynamics of that.
Let's say you want to
worry about the kinetics.
So essentially, how fast can
you get that lithium in and out?
So you essentially
want a diffusion
constant in that material.
Well, this is fairly well-suited
for kinetic Monte Carlo rather
than molecular dynamics.
First of all, the
rates are fairly slow.
So doing anything with
transition state theory
is going to help you a lot.
And you have transitions
between well-defined positions.
The atoms go from
one well-defined site
to another site.
So if you had dilute
diffusion, you
could just use
random walk theory.
So in that case, diffusion
is sort of trivial.
All you need is an activation
barrier and a prefactor.
All the rest you know.
You have the lattice
constant, which
is actually the jump linked.
And you have the geometric
correlation factor.
These are all known.
The things in green you
would have to calculate.
But let's do calculation.
Random walks only apply when
you have dilute diffusion.
What I mean with
dilute diffusion--
it's when the carrier of
diffusion is very dilute,
so it doesn't
interact with itself.
So if you have a
substitutional diffusion
with very dilute
vacancy concentration,
then this would apply.
The problem, of
course, that we're
going to look at the
lithium cobalt [INAUDIBLE]
is by definition not dilute.
You essentially
can go all the way
from all lithium on the site
to all vacancies on the site.
So you go to very
non-dilute regimes.
If you want to do that, you
need to actually simulate
the diffusion-- and you may
have even done that in the MD
homework--
by doing some kinetic
model and then tracking
the root mean
square displacement.
This is sort of a simple
form for the self-diffusion.
The chemical diffusion
constant, which
is the one you would use
in macroscopic theories,
is the self-diffusion times
the thermodynamic factor.
But the thermodynamic factor
is essentially the derivative
of the chemical potential
of the composition,
so that you already have from
the thermodynamic calculation.
OK.
So I have a few more slides
here that I already used,
so I'm going to
[INAUDIBLE] through them.
You remember how we
did the thermodynamics?
We built a lattice model.
We calculate a lot of
lithium vacancy arrangement,
build a cluster expansion,
and do Monte Carlo on that.
And that gives you
the phase diagram.
Let me skip that since
we did that already.
Those are the interactions.
OK.
How would you do
kinetic Monte Carlo?
I sort of also mentioned that.
You would now execute all the
exchanges in the Monte Carlo
that look like
diffusive processes.
And you would execute
them with the proper rate.
So you would have an
activation barrier in there.
OK.
I think I said all this.
So here's an example
of how that works out.
If you calculate barriers
in lithium cobalt oxide
and you then do a kinetic
Monte Carlo simulation,
you keep track of the root
mean square displacement.
You get the macroscopic
diffusivity.
And as you see, it varies
by orders of magnitude.
It's 10 to the minus 7 here
centimeters squared per second.
And it's 10 to
the minus 13 here.
You can already see
that you would never
get to all these time scales
with a simple dynamics model.
OK.
How you get
activation barriers--
typically, we get
this with what's
called a nudge
elastic band model.
You know, what's the issue in
finding activation barrier?
Well, you know
the initial state,
and you know the final state.
This is not necessarily
the state of an atom.
You really should think of these
as two states in phase space.
Now, for simplicity,
you can think, well,
only one atom moves, is
different, between those two
states.
But in reality, more
stuff is different.
Because if the atom has
moved, the other atoms
may have relaxed around it.
So these are really
states in phase space.
So what you have to find
is the path between the two
with the lowest energy
maximum along that path.
That's essentially
the activated state.
And a very practical
way to find is
what's called a nudged
elastic band model, which
is essentially that you do
a simulation on many systems
at a time.
And all the systems live
at intermediate states
between the final state
and the initial state.
And the way you keep them
there is interesting.
Rather than optimizing the
energy of each system, what
you optimize is the
sum of their energies,
the sum of their
Hamiltonian values,
plus some spring constant,
basically plus some energy
penalty, which is associated
with the difference in
coordinates between
the two systems.
And what that tends
to do is actually,
since this is a quadratic in
the difference in corniness,
it tends to spread out
the systems along the path
between the two states.
I mean, think of it.
If I got rid of this,
so if I set k to 0,
then I'm going to minimize this.
So they're all going
to go down here.
But what do you actually
do is you hold one here.
You hold one there.
And then because of the
harmonic potential between them,
you tend to end up with
systems that live in between.
So it's a very elegant way
of finding minimum energy
paths between states.
It's called the
elastic band method
or the nudged
elastic band method.
And there's a whole bunch
of variants of it as well.
It's the perfect
parallelization.
You may have noticed.
If you want to do,
say, 10 replicas--
so you want to do 10
points along the path--
you run on 10 processors.
Because it's the same
system, they pretty much
run about the same
amount of time.
They never have to
talk to each other.
They have to talk to each other
on extremely rare occasion
when they exchange coordinates.
That's it.
So it's a perfect
parallelization tool.
If you do that in lithium cobalt
oxide, you have a complication.
Just to show you how the data
for that kinetic Monte Carlo
simulation was derived, the
yellow is the lithium here.
These are oxygens,
the big red balls.
The way you can diffuse
from this side to that side
is straight through
the oxygen bond.
And if you do that,
this is obtained
by elastic band method.
So these are the replicas.
So this is initial stage.
This is the final state.
And so you get an activation
barrier of about 0.85.
So it's very nice how you
get these activation curves.
But the problem is that there's
two paths in this material.
So already you're starting to
run into a particular problem
of kinetic Monte Carlo.
Let's say you thought
that was the path.
Well, you'd be very wrong
because there's another path.
And that's one when the
outcome actually, rather
than going straight
through this bond,
it takes a curve into this
tetrahedron and comes back out.
And that's actually a path,
if you do elastic band, that
is so much lower.
It's only about 200
millielectron volts.
And it sort of shows
the real problem
you can run into that, when
you do kinetic Monte Carlo,
you have to assume what your
paths are for transitions.
And if you don't get them right,
you can be seriously wrong.
And that's one of the
nice things of MD,
that it's unbiased.
So it would find
these things for you.
But these are actually
the only two paths.
And of course, because of
the activation barrier,
this is so much lower.
This is pretty much the one
that gets executed almost
all the time.
The difference between 0.2
electron volts and 0.8 electron
volts at room
temperature is amazing.
It's, I think, 5, 6 orders of
magnitude in rate constant.
You just have to calculate the
exponential of each of these.
One of the problems you have
whenever you have two rate
constants is that, when
you do your Monte Carlo,
you can only scale
the fastest one away.
So you have essentially
one scale factor
in the time of your
Monte Carlo simulation.
So when you do multiple
time scales, when
you have multiple
time scales, it
gets very inefficient to
do kinetic Monte Carlo.
But this works.
You can get diffusion constants.
This is with
elastic band method.
This is the activation barrier
for that low energy mechanism
as a function of
lithium concentration,
so very dependent
on concentration.
So you can do your
kinetic Monte Carlo.
And then you have these,
and you can go all the way
to macroscopic stimulation.
Then you can solve
a fixed equation
and actually look at diffusion
on the scale of microns.
So it's a fairly simplistic
way of course graining.
OK.
So I'm going to end just
giving you some reference.
If you want to read more about
the quasi-continuum method,
there's these great papers
by Miller and Tadmor.
These are actually
somewhat similar,
but the 202 version
is an update.
These are not the
original papers,
but they're actually
sometimes more pedagogical
than the original papers.
But you'll find the
references in there
to the original papers.
The problem of sort of dynamics
at that scale is my own work.
The accelerated MD, there's a
series of papers by Art Voter.
But this annual review
of materials research
is, I think, a great review
if you want to read about it.
And the lithium cobalt
application is in a few papers,
but it's quite elaborate.
The whole idea of
kinetic Monte Carlo
and parameterizing
activation barriers
is quite elaborately
discussed in this paper.
So I think we're done a
little early, but that's fine.
So I'm going to end here.
And I'll see you on Thursday
for the lecture from Ford.